obstiné hargneux ouais
il est consciencieux
un sportif complet ces tempéraments bien
sûr
bonjour on est chez moi
allez-y rentrée donc cédric andrieux 30
50 ou protease de métier et a passionné
par le vélo la passion oui oui depuis
longue date qui arrivait en suivant mon
cousin qui pourrait dans de grandes
courses cyclistes en bretagne et en le
voyant gagner des grandes courses comme
des 100 breton
et c'est tous les jours trois quatre
fois par semaine les samedis les
dimanches sans déplacement aussi dès
l'âge de 15 16 ans après j'ai commencé à
travailler forcément je vais arrêter les
études aussi j'ai tout cas elle tout
plaquer quoi j'étais en bas qui vont
enfin première j'ai même pas passer le
bac du coup donc j'ai arrêté le vélo la
même année le bac a ras-le-bol un
burn-out moi je pense on arrivait à peu
près la même période
même souvenez de points différents moi
j'arrive de normandie d'huile arrive de
bretagne quand même pas la même chose
et en fait on s'est rencontrés ici par
hasard par hasard en fait on cherchait
des colocations l'un et l'autre pour se
loger dans le sud est
c'est là pour se rencontrer voilà qui
est posée sur un home trainer ah non pas
matin midi et soir mais le plus possible
mais c'est vrai que la maison n'est pas
très très grande donc quand généralement
unis si tu cites c'est la vie du
cycliste
le vélo c'est son premier moyen de
locomotion peu importe où ils aillent
c'est à vélo au travail faire les
courses ou quoi que ce soit après la
compétition en vélo s'est retrouvé des
sensations qu'il avait étant plus jeune
et j'ai sorti quelques quelques bons
souvenirs dirige donc
donc qu'à l'époque mon titre de champion
bretagne par équipes juniors et
deuxièmement la troisième place aux
championnats de france handisport il ya
deux ans deux moments forts il ya eu
l'avant et l'après accident j'ai perdu
mon tibia droit donc j'ai suivi une
intervention juge été amputé de la jambe
droite cours du tibia bonjour excusez
quoi placer le programme paracyclistes
de l'année 2015
da surpasser son handicap fruits parce
que on ne remarque pas on ne voit pas
les vues dans son boulot aussi parce que
j'ai pu échanger avec lui à travers une
journée sur les amputations et je les
bus se débrouiller accueillir les jeunes
est amputé ce n'est pas lui amputer
c'était les autres quoi voilà souvent
effacement ce qui se passe ici c'est au
fait pourquoi cycliste de lobbies ne
vois pas ça comme on n'a pas le mot
rapide en tête donc souvent des boîtes
trop vite
il ya danger par le comportement des
automobilistes par la france sur des
routes pas forcément tout le temps
adapté malgré tout on s'arrête pas
j'étais tellement orthopédie c'est mon
boulot
ça y est il que découvert que suite à
mon amputation
je suis rentré en centre de rééducation
fonctionnelle et mon propre procès this
a voulu me faire découvrir le métier
donc de là est née la passion pour ce
métier passion j'aime effacer le
handicap cédé face et l'handicap au
maximum des gens voire l'annuler
totalement je trouve que dans le boulot
en tout cas il
il n'est pas en situation de handicap
parce qu'il fait tout comme nous en fait
très peu qui pratiquent une activité
sportive
il pense que quand ils sont amputés bas
à la vie s'arrête
sauf que ben pour certains tout cas pour
ceux qui sont imputés tibio c'est à dire
en dessous du genou ils peuvent refaire
pratiquement tout ce qui faisait avant
allez-vous la compréhension du patient
oui un peu plus facilement même si
chaque patient est différent au bout du
compte chaque patient la différence que
ce soit au niveau du dos et qu'il a pu
faire soit au niveau du lac aux de
l'amputation
c'est vrai qu'entre un diabétique et un
trauma c'est différent l'âge du patient
chacun sait à peu près ce que c'est les
moniales et plus et dans celle ci
je me sens pas si différent je me sens
égal à tout le monde
donc comme je dis l'handicap c'est face
à ce moment là
fais du vélo avec deux fois moins de
muscles que les autres il est classé
pareil il n'y a pas de classement
particulier pour lui et et on le prépare
ici à la réunion dans ce cadre là pour
essayer de l'amener au plus haut niveau
en 10 sport du jour n'est pas qu'ils
allaient terminer mon goût les yeux
et
j'aimerais qu'ils nous ramènent au titre
de champion de france ce serait super
beau quoi et c'est un truc qui
n'oubliera jamais et je lui sais tu
pourquoi pas aller aux paralympiques
faut qu'il aille au bout peu importe ce
qu'on pense peu importe dans quel état
il est peu importe ce qui se passe il va
passer par plusieurs étapes mais il faut
que l'objectif ce toit dans tous les cas
atteints qui deviennent l'image en tout
cas peut-être du handisport réunionnais
qui l'encouragé que à travers lui
d'autres patients aient envie de faire
une activité sportive aussi je suis de
finir sa saison en force et éviter les
chutes au maximum faut oser oser oser
remonter sur un vélo a osé reprendre la
marche chose est remonté dans les eaux
faisait aussi aux chutes ma font
remonter